29 anos de trabalho na cidade sol
sou feliz como eu faço eu sou da bahia
assim gera bahia eu vou desistir do meu
bairro joão paulo ii a bahia chegou e
falou que eu tive na cabeça
paulo
eu tinha um sonho de que os seguiam os
passos daquele grande arquiteto
brasileiro paulo a cidade grande
paulo portas de são paulo o crescimento
de são paulo 11 anos que desenha a
passar-se escola eb2 pessoal papel na
rua com um carro assim a imó 17 anos e
comecei a maior empresa de bebidas
premium bilhão o pessoal está ganhando
eu sabia que era nem em 2000 e
funcionários jogavam fora
eu comecei esse claro que a babá e
liderava o resíduo na comida lava ele
comecei a juntar e aquilo foi o
crescimento do meu
tudo aquilo que foi o crescimento da
minha criação de comprar os meus
cadernos comprar meus lábios
daniel raphael certo e ajudar a minha
tinha as mesmas o alimento em casa e aí
eu fui pro vinho quando chegou a época
eu encontrei com os da noite
você gosta de fazer isso
foi quando resolvi de contas de empresas
que eu trabalhava como se coloca nas
ruas de são paulo fazer asfalto nas
empresas com a empregada da empresa
tinham muito coagido muito aprendi com
que eu comecei a perder ali de aula
o emprego deu um pouco de trabalho
eu acho que o benefício e isso nos
trouxe o meio ambiente sempre sobre o
meio ambiente ltda agradece a evolução
do trabalho nesse caso o trabalho que
fizemos nas ruas de são paulo e força
física que nós filmes onde se é nós era
tratado com os tons nos casos que não
tinha uma lo
hoje nós temos uma valorização mundial
que é um trabalho que fazemos pela
limpeza da nossa cidade e isso foi nos
deixou muito feliz muito é reciclável
consegui a minha família tenho os meus
dez filhos sete nenhum gol stay
pensa o uso 9 10
nesses dez filhos eu na reciclagem
eu comecei a falar com esse estuda forma
pra vocês e coisas boas a milha e senão
seguir muito o exemplo do parque do lago
de vôos empresas fazem isso porque isso
aqui é a sinceridade do homem o homem
tem o direito de lutar pela família se
tem e o oab se cravo formei os filhos e
estou com três filhos aqui hoje que a a
oitava a 9ª ea 10ª festa ali e ali e irá
ser doada
a minha vida só minha família
são todos vocês que eu digo obrigado a
sociedade
obrigado a toda a população que hoje nos
valoriza hoje nos dá o apoio nos dá
dignidade ele poderia dizer eu sou um
catador de papel de ter a minha
valorização que contando hoje estou aqui
fazendo uma palestra para vocês um
respeito um com dignidade e mostrando o
que é que a sensibilidade do povo
brasileiro em quem eles querem que faça
o bem da cidade
eu como ter esperança de ter uma
habilidade de ser que nem os carros vai
hoje eu sou um cidadão da reciclagem que
me considero o fla
as obras de arte que tinha a fazer
porque a sombra do álbuns brasília e
muitas áreas que ele fez com ela e mais
de outros lugares do mundo
o país e deixou um legado dele a todos
os brasileiros que aqui 9v pra que a
juventude tivesse uma tendência na
cabeça dele e que se for má assim que
tivermos a 'engenharia do novo país que
cesse mais eu vou nesse mais através do
que ele deixou para todos nós
brasileiros o respeito à dignidade
é isso que o caráter de voltar e fazer
meu papel e construir nunca nice e deixe
qualquer fora não guarda que um dia você
vai tirar aquele ciclo que você fez um
papel e vai fazer ele a arte em evolução
e determinação para que você tenha um
legado
está de ter alegria em quando eu
trabalhando na reciclagem surgiu o casal
um dia aqui na porta da minha casa pezão
uma carga para o comprador de rua que
para usar melhor o casal acaba dividindo
o dinheiro da minha chance e cinco reais
o inter aqui em causa aquele casal quer
ele quer reformar abril vontade de
chorar de hotel a noite pensando
multidões de pessoas médico lista de
massagem
iniciada por isso transforma a vida da
gente é aquela pessoa que era maltratado
coletor de lixo é que era tratado com um
mundo em que passaram por agentes botar
uma volta
temos que agradecer ao ppi que são os
grafiteiros que pessoas que muitos
tempos atrás
é o criticado porque num mundo à parte
seria fechado você dizia o grafiteiro
veio aqui ficou muda
o gap de é um artista de rua
ele é um artista nem parei ele é um
artista i porta de aço
ele é uma tinta mundo e torre mas que
ele deixa um legado em vassouras
quem faz arte em fase de demonstração
quem faz a alegria de um povo mas a
alegria sua no jovem de que vai passar
vou e i've hora que obra bonita de
pintura bonita vai fotografar vai contar
uma história daquilo que é o grafiteiro
que antes eram discriminados e ele parar
e pensar jec
nós estamos percebe que alguém nos
apoiar
então ao tomem se nós a nova só vamos
pensar um só então sirvam de ser legal
aí o jeito nenhum óleo do golfo sabão
para vezes não consegui chegar até nós
mas eles foram até nós de sebo ali
calçar botas de borracha descer até o
final foi lá e cá pela nossas mãos e
disse que vamos juntos crescer que vocês
têm valor e assim então
até hoje recebe um cada dia mais e
sempre ser o mestre trabalhando pela a
nossa cidade ea única tem que continuar
a nossa cidade merece o respeito à nossa
cidade merece o nosso determinação de
cuidar dela somos nós que vivemos nela
são paulo é a minha vida
são paulo é a minha família desde
criança no mundo com o são paulo e se
dizer que é um catador de papel passado
por são paulo fácil fácil por vocês que
mora no condomínio e tem o lixo pode
jogar eu faço lá é cargo aquele nicho
pra mim é sobreviver
vocês juntos somos nós que devemos
cuidar da nossa cidade
somos nós que devemos ter o o dever ea
habilidade de deixar nossa cidade sempre
linda e brigar com aqueles que surgiu há
até muitos próprios governantes que às
vezes querem tirar de nós o nosso
sustento
o nosso respeito à nossa civilização
vocês vêem aqui ó
eu fui homenageado na rua com o meu nome
passando disso aqui
o mma informou uma surpresa dentro do
museu no elenco é combinar nossa era
ruim assim
sempre participei de catadores através
de um pique
participei de outros é beijos mas fui
até a porta voz do museu da civilização
por ajudar a cuidar da nossa cidade
tudo isso pra mim foi um agradecimento
maior da minha vida aqui na paulista é
algo que muitos de vocês sobre carros
causar danos às vezes não é muitas vezes
a ignorância de milhares de famílias de
são mateus cidade tiradentes guaianases
200 lag taquá não basta aos apreendida
e é que nós quiserem ocorrer dados num
tom da noite feliz não aprende as capas
dos caras carroça ou seja os guardas
disse nash à labuta vão debater o pré
natal de seu pai dela
nós temos como resolver a paz amanhã o
pique e nós vamos procurar os direitos
nós vocês vão ter que devolver essas
causas
portanto recebeu na minha calça num
prémio nossos carros
aprendam arriscar dizer é um recado a
eles pra que eles respeitem o nosso
trabalho
a gente sabe que fazendo na cidade e que
essas carroças online nós precisamos que
elas sejam devolvidas aos catadores que
seja sempre isso a dignidade e aqui
nesses 29 anos
estou completando 30 anos vamos ter o
direito de ser cortada
é um prazer para todos os brasileiros
não é cortar esse título para nós é uma
salvação do nosso bebê de água e
precisamos respeitar são que precisamos
implantar a área envolvida nos trabalhos
o jovem não foi contada
aí o petróleo novos sítios e 15/16
barris do óleo cru circular que dê tudo
isso é um benefício que nós fazemos pela
natureza
não sou eu um sonho dos nossos catadores
a vocês que a google a reciclagem
a não ser que os ajudam a formar morava
ali em cuidar daquilo proteger o a minha
família só vocês
juntos o que nos dá uma mão são vocês
que nos abraça só vocês que não há
sustentação de viver e que a gente possa
cuidar da nossa família com dignidade
com respeito
só através de todos vocês na união na
força e no respeito que têm por os
catadores e aí vai o meu agradecimento a
vocês todos
ficou aqui nesta palestra da gente e
tenho certeza que o pt fica mais
agradecido de poder fazer mais com nós
mas pela nossa cidade e ao nosso lado
porque o pt luta por nós em todos os
momentos
começou um ano difícil e dá o pão nos
mais difícil nos fácil e tudo que estão
por nós e tenho certeza que vocês todos
bons assembléia ao lado no bank track
desordem mais pelos catadores e e
administradores tenham sejam mais
respeitados na nossa cidade de são paulo